[Music]
it's hard to believe that next month
will be the five year anniversary since
your lymphoma diagnosis and of course
the uh you know spinal surgery that has
confined you to this wheelchair it feels
like yesterday yeah
I always tell people oh I've only been
in a chair for like three years it's
five I know that a side effect of the
chemo has been that your bones are
brittle I had that broken tip FIB
shattered leg in a tragic accident freak
accident my chair slammed me into a wall
first time it's ever happened my right
leg it's my dancing leg and you're like
I just want to walk I walked on to 11
flights I take the chair down to the
bridge and then step onto the flight
then this happened so it set me back
you're in good spirits it's like bionic
now right you're super romantic I can
leave you know buildings in a single
bound the dance mom star is now cancer
free and determined to walk again after
battling a rare highly aggressive
lymphoma that left her paralyzed from
the neck down in 2018. it's my piece I
like to swim
in the pool I love it it's my place I
feel normal I don't feel paralyzed I can
walk across the pool I can balance I
swim I love it how much of a daily
struggle is it for you to you know kind
of like live your life it's rough yeah
you know
behind closed doors people don't know
about they're getting out of bed right
and uh all your bathrooming things and
you know stuff that people don't like to
really talk about when they see me out
and I'm in makeup my hair's done I'm
moving I'm grooving
they're like she's great she's fine they
don't really see what happens before
that and I hate that I'm like slow
moving yeah it takes me a while to do
things because there's nothing slow
about yet no I'm not like that normally
I'm like let's go let's go let's go
hurry hurry hurry who is helping you day
to day
no one I live alone you yeah I have uh
caregiver slash housekeeper that comes
once a week
and she's fabulous but uh that's it
otherwise I'm on my own so when I see
something in that closet that's way up
higher way in the back I'm like
can I ask you how this has impacted your
dating life what dating life last we
spoke I think you had a man yeah yeah
I've raised enough children right let's
put it that way Arch the back lengthen
lengthen yeah Abby is happily single and
returning to reality TV in her own
version of Dance Moms that's still in
the works for years I have trained kids
trained kids train kids some turn out to
be Stars five Broadway shows make more
money than their parents ever dreamed of
making themselves and other kids
fail miserably it has nothing to do with
that Network it's not like I'm going
back I see this is all on it okay so
what can we explain is it going to be
classic Abby Lee Miller though you know
uh it's pasta Gabby Lee Miller but
there's little ones and there's moms and
the talent
yes
okay it's not Dance Moms without the
moms exactly but it's it's different
roll the studio you idiot they don't one
of the things we loved about it was the
drama can we expect you to go toe-to-toe
with some of the moms yeah and you can
see me go toe-to-toe with the dude with
the older kids to themselves so there is
drama yeah 16 to 22 there okay those are
the ages of the kids that watched the
show when they were little and now
they're grown up so they are super fans
you know you have some pretty famous
alumni right from Dance Moms um is there
anyone you like to see maybe make a
guest appearance well yes uh we're
looking at a young lady named Brynn okay
that came in uh
I think possibly Kalani and Kendall will
be invited and now what about Maddie uh
definitely not naughty okay after her
little Cosmo article if you win it makes
my studio look better
Maddie you didn't win Maddie Ziegler
who's now 20 was on Dance Moms for six
seasons until her exit in 2016. she
slammed the show last year calling it
toxic you have to worry about the win
got it no mishaps so you haven't reached
out to Maddie to participate in any way
no she absolutely wants nothing to do
with me okay but JoJo you guys still
that's sad but yeah it is what it is
yeah JoJo absolutely because she's
dancing yeah JoJo keeps posting you know
dance steps and turns and this and that
and I have to correct her all the time
when you're turning I wanted to look
like she can't stop but you and JoJo
stop released yeah I just talked to her
yeah because I know she did post a tick
tock with a throwback video of you
yelling at her well if you're so good
you don't really need to be a part of me
again
[Music]
we look bad do you view yourself as a
reality TV villain do I view myself
no no
I did
on 21 different towns I was convicted of
one right I went to prison because I was
maybe gonna walk away from a vacation
home in Florida after the crash in 2008.
who else does that no one
I was indicted because of the way I was
on the television show The Way I was
shown on the show Abby served eight
months in federal prison after pleading
guilty to felony bankruptcy fraud in
2016 which means she has something in
common with fellow reality stars Todd
and Julie Chrisley they are currently
serving a combined 19-year sentence for
bank fraud and tax evasion they're in
real trouble that's a long time and I
heard that you actually reached out to
Todd via DMS and emails right well I had
damned him a few times and I said be
careful you know if they want you
they're going to get you and then all of
a sudden I get I think it was an email
back saying oh my gosh I'm so sorry I
didn't even know people could DM me
direct message me he goes I didn't even
know that existed on there and I've
never answered you and I'm sorry this is
before you went to prison yes this is a
long time ago got it was there something
that you learned the hard way that you
hope they don't experience I don't think
Todd and Julia are gonna have that
trouble because they were like a mom and
dad they're going to share the same
problems that other moms and dads had
with their kids you know I I just think
it's a different chemistry there
and he was funny it was fun he was
hilarious yeah I think he said that he's
uh kind of bougie do you think he can
survive he's not gonna be able to handle
like the soap
and the towels
and that you know it's gonna have to
well I think he'll do some trade outs
there's a way to survive in there how do
you think Julie's gonna be able to
handle prison she's tough she handled
Todd all these years up she could handle
those people are you kidding today Abby
is focused on giving back with Chef
Bruno Serrato making meals for the
non-profit Katarina's club which
provides assistance to low-income
families in California the whole coveted
pandemic funding is now ending and these
kids still need to eat they need a good
meal every day to survive so how can
folks outside it's
Katarina's club.org please go five
dollars can feed a family of four you'll
be cooking with the kids right
absolutely I'm so excited about it when
the kids see me
it's gonna be amazing I can't wait to
hand a child a meal and visit with them
and laugh and they're going to be so
excited she's prioritizing self-care too
E.T was there as she underwent this
procedure with celebrity dermatologist
Dr Mariano buso to diminish sunspots
first let's get this the skin right yeah
look at the face right he's gonna like
fix me okay you know but I like to go on
the Sun what is Abby Lee Miller without
her tan you know what I'm saying what
cosmetic surgery are you interested in
getting next
no
come on Abby and a reduction she says
she's single and ready to mingle there
you go okay I love it
[Music]